Ladies and gentlemen,
we're here not
just to mourn the passing
of some great friends,
but to celebrate their
life on this earth
and look back with fondness on
the time we spent with them.
Somebody who, without
ever calling any attention
to themselves or hogging the
spotlight, saved thousands
of Android developers
from writing line
upon line of boilerplate code.
But now, they've moved on
to the great deprecation
warning in the sky.
I'm talking of, course, about
BaseGameActivity and Game
Helper, who were
taken away from us,
some might say, a bit too
soon, by a change list
just a few weeks ago.
Yes if you've been
following Google Play Game
Services on Android
for a while, you
may have noticed that our sample
code has recently changed.
Whereas before, all of
our sample applications
inherited from BaseGameActivity,
a class that used GameHelper
to do a lot of heavy lifting,
both of these classes
have disappeared from our
sample apps and have also
vanished from our documentation,
almost as if they never
existed in the first place.
So what happened?
Well you see, back when Google
Play Game Services first
launched, Android
applications were
great for using Google
services, as long as you only
needed to use one of them.
But Play Games,
as you'll recall,
used three-- the Play Games API,
the Plus API, and the AppState
API.
And it turns out
that, in the old days,
the process for using
more than one API client
was something that we
in the engineering field
like to refer to
as-- and this is
a technical term--
a bit of a mess.
You see, to connect the player
properly to Google Play Games,
the first thing you had to do
was create your three clients.
And you'd collect the
scopes you'd need and call
connect on the game's client.
So far so good, right?
Well then, if that
connection failed
because your player
might need to sign in,
it's actually no big deal.
Just remember where we are so
that once the player has signed
in, we do know where
to continue from.
Then, of course, you
need do the same thing
with the Plus client.
Can't do these things
in the other order,
incidentally, unless
we want to present
our user with multiple sign-in
dialogue boxes, which is never
really a good idea.
Of course, if that
Plus client fails,
you'll definitely need
to handle that, as well.
Oh, but if it fails a second
time, because the user said,
I don't want to sign in,
you'll need resolve this
by disconnecting the
Plus client first
and then the Game's client.
You don't want to do
that in the wrong order,
because that will put
your game in a bad state
and you certainly
don't want that.
Of course, if all
that worked, you
could do the whole thing
again with the App State
client with all the
same rules as before.
But only do this after you've
connected your other clients,
and if it fails a second
time, disconnect everything
in the reverse order.
App State Plus and then Games.
So easy, right?
So this is basically why
GameHelper and BaseGameActivity
existed.
The multiple state machine was
the same for every project,
and so rather than have
hundreds of developers
write the same
boilerplate code, we
decided it would make
more sense to create
a reusable component
for anybody to use.
So we abstracted all this
away into a GameHelper class,
composited that into
BaseGameActivity,
and then had BaseGameActivity
call all the relevant methods.
All your game needed to do was
inherit from BaseGameActivity
and we did most of the
setup work for you.
But then in early 2014,
something magical happened.
The Play Services team
released the GoogleApiClient,
a drastic improvement in
the way the APIs work.
This is actually a really
nice chunk of code.
It's very pretty.
It's beautiful and wondrous.
But with the introduction
of the GoogleApiClient,
if you wanted to use multiple
Google services at once,
like Games, Plus, Saved Games
or even Drive or YouTube,
the GoogleApiClient
handles it all for you.
Here's how it works.
Step one, you're going
to create a builder.
Step two, add your
APIs and your scopes.
Step three, add some
callback listeners.
Don't forget to call build.
And then, call connect
on this new client
and you're pretty much done.
You'll catch sign-in problems
in your onConnection failed call
back.
You can analyze the code here,
and depending on the error code
you get back, you could show a
sign-in dialogue if necessary.
In your onConnect listener, you
would start making API calls.
And in your activities
onStop method,
you would call disconnect,
and the GoogleApiClient
will properly disconnect
all of your services.
And you've got a nice
straightforward API client
with some great
error handling, just
the way nature, or at least
our engineering team, intended.
But with that, there's
a whole lot less stuff
that the GameHelper classes
suddenly needed to do for you,
and its role
gradually transitioned
from helpful class that
did lots of heavy lifting
behind the scenes to yet
another layer of code
you needed to worry
about and keep
in sync with a few helpful
bits still remaining.
So what we've done
is we've taken
those remaining helpful bits
and, swoosh, converted them
into static methods in a new
class called BaseGameUtils.
And then we have deprecated both
GameHelper and BaseGameActivity
and are no longer using them in
any of our sample applications.
So what does this
all mean for you?
Well, for any of your
existing code, nothing.
Any code that you have
that's currently working
will continue to work.
If for some reason,
however, you decide
you need to replace your
BaseGameActivity or GameHelper
classes with the versions
we have archived on GitHub,
you're going to see some
deprecation warnings
in the log.
But for the rest of
you, all this means
is that, when you're digging
around in our sample apps
or documentation,
you find yourself
saying, "Wait a second.
I could've sworn there used to
be a whole helper class around
here somewhere that I
was supposed to use.
Am I going crazy?"
Well no, you're not going crazy.
At least not for that reason.
We've just dropped these classes
from our samples and our docs.
Now if you want to see
this code in action,
my advice would
be to take a look
at Trivial Quest, our extremely
simple-- some might say
trivial-- sample application
that demonstrates
the proper way to sign in
and handle connections using
the Google API service.
And you can always
review our documentation,
which has now been updated to
support our new GoogleApiClient
world.
And so with that,
we finally bid adieu
to BaseGameActivity
and GameHelper,
gone from this world
but still in our hut.
Wait, what?
What do you mean
they're not dead?
They're on a beach in Miami?
Yeah, you know,
this is something
you could have brought
to my attention
before I bought
all these flowers.
Well, all right.
To heck with this, then.
I'm changing out of this suit.
This thing's itchy.
So, uh, who's in
the coffin, anyway?
You know what?
Nevermind.
Don't tell me.
I don't want to know.
[SAD ORGAN MUSIC]